today's episode is sponsored by blinka
Stu the app that lets you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blink it's totally
free and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blink Escom slash david pakman
I put the link right below this video
we're going to start today talking about
John Bolton and there is so much to say
and so many different angles to this
story so let's get right into it one of
Donald Trump's former national security
advisors because he said many it's very
close to releasing a book the book is
scheduled to be released on Tuesday June
23rd we have a bunch of the claims that
are in the book to tell you about
momentarily but the first part of this
is about Donald Trump and the Justice
Department under Donald Trump's AG
William bar working really hard to
suppress the release of the book the I
the story needs a disclaimer now I want
to be I'm gonna keep saying this today
because it's important because it's been
a few months since we last talked about
John Bolton's book John Bolton is
absolutely horrible John Bolton is of
the worst of the worst when it comes to
his political worldview he's one of the
key architects of the 2003 Iraq war
which doesn't seem he regrets being a
part of to this day he's a horrible
neoconservative he's not someone that
progressives would ever consider an ally
on policy and someone whose entire moral
compass is fundamentally broken so I the
reason I want to do this is there's
already some supposedly lists out there
talking about liberals are falling for
both they're falling all over themselves
to praise Bolton bad people sometimes
tell the truth in other words bad people
aren't always lying John Bolton seems to
be a fierce advocate for what he
believes is right and true and he
doesn't tend to get pushed around I
almost always disagree with him about
what is right in this particular case
Bolton has decided that it is correct
and profitable and this is important
we're going to get into that to tell the
story as he sees it
what happened when he was Donald Trump's
national security adviser this is not
praise of John Bolton and I'm gonna go
back to that
so the Trump administration has been
panicking and they have sued Bolton to
try to prevent the release of the book
Trump's Justice Department is trying to
suppress the book remember this they
said this would be the most transparent
administration ever the most for free
speech administration ever they're going
through any number of different
arguments trying anything they can to
see what sticks
including claiming that the publication
of Bolton's book risks compromising
national security now there is something
funny in that there is some truth in the
national security concerns around
Bolton's book but what I mean by that is
what Bolton alleges in the book which I
will get to is so damning to Donald
Trump that it exposes the United States
to being taken advantage of by showing
how incompetent and clueless Donald
Trump is it actually might encourage our
adversaries to try to take advantage of
the United States
knowing how incompetent Donald Trump is
according to the book but from a legal
perspective these arguments are all very
tired they're likely not going to work
partially thanks to the First Amendment
to the Constitution of the United States
now in the lawsuit against Bolton
there's a few different arguments the
lawsuit says Bolton violated the
contract he signed when he became
national security advisor by writing the
book they make another argument in the
lawsuit that says Bolton has not allowed
enough time for the book to be vetted to
see if it contains government secrets
Donald Trump the other day said he
thinks if the book gets published Bolton
will have criminal problems but before
we get into that here is Trump saying
any conversation with him is de facto
classified which is another argument
he's making about why Bolton's book
shouldn't be published and somebody said
he went out and wrote a book if he wrote
a book I can't imagine that he can
because that's highly classified
information even conversations with me
they're highly classified I told that to
the Attorney General before I will
consider every kind
sation with me as president highly
classified now that isn't true
presidents can choose to classify or
declassify whatever they want but there
is no legal basis to say retro actively
every conversation that I had with
Bolton is classified that's an insanely
broad legal claim courts are very
unlikely to accept such a claim let's
keep going though here's more of what
Trump said about Bolton being a criminal
so that would mean that if he wrote a
book and if the book gets out he's
broken the law and I would think that he
would have criminal problems I hope so
otherwise I mean they put a sailor in
jail because he sent a photograph of his
bed and a an engine of an old submarine
and if this guy's writing writing things
about conversations or about anything
and maybe he's not telling the truth
he's been known not to tell the truth a
lot so legal experts believe that Bolton
would not have legal problems but his
publisher would also potentially be
liable there and the publisher has
obviously done a huge legal review
before the book is going to print the
First Amendment is quite strong here as
well now there's a footnote in the
lawsuit against Bolton where the
Department of Justice is asking a court
to ban every bookstore in the United
States from selling the book that is
critical of President Trump what would
we be saying if in any other country we
saw a court being asked by a president
to ban book stores from selling a book
that's critical of the president just
think about that and when we see all of
these supposedly enlightened hot takes
from some on the Left saying oh it's
liberals falling for it again now
believing Bolton who in 2003 was the bad
guy what would we be saying if a
different country was trying to use the
courts to prevent book stores from
publishing a book now the reality in
terms of the vetting is that the
manuscript was first sent to the White
House's National Security Council in
December that's six seven months ago at
this point and ultimately this is not
about classified information this is not
about state secrets this is not really
about national
security this is about a book whose
claims and content is very embarrassing
to Donald Trump that's really what this
is about now I have to tell you
Trump's concern may be overblown to a
degree because yes now that we found out
what's in the book which I'll tell you
in a moment a lot of media coverage of
it but most trumpets
aren't going to buy and read a book with
several hundred pages that's not what
Trump is to do most trumpets are going
to see what Fox News and Breitbart and
Oh a n and you know Mark Levin say about
the book and that will be what they
believe so I think some of the concern
may be overblown but what we've learned
so far is that Donald Trump is focused
solely on re-election and to the extent
that he believes the book may hurt his
re-election he's going to do everything
he can to suppress the book now
we're going to talk more about
skepticism in a moment we should apply
skepticism here to John Bolton as we
always should when there is a book
because John Bolton is going to make
money from this book if John Bolton's
only priority was to get the truth out
he could have been doing interview seven
months ago and telling us what's in the
book I'm going to argue later on in the
show that John Bolton is actually a
traitor to the United States for waiting
seven months to tell us about such
damning allegations against Donald Trump
so there's no doubt that there's a
financial calculation here for John
Bolton that doesn't tell us whether the
claims in the book are true or false and
we have to see if the claims pass the
sniff test and they do we have to see if
the claims are similar to those that
have been made by others who have spent
time around around Donald Trump and they
are so is john bolton hypocritical in
the sense that he didn't testify for the
house impeachment trial and now he's
publishing a book to make money with
absolutely bombshell claims when he
could have told us about these seven
months ago absolutely and I'm gonna slam
him for it in about 15 minutes
but that doesn't mean that the claims
are untrue
and that is what we are going to be
talking about again I don't know that
this is really going to change Trump's
standing with trumpets who aren't really
gonna read the book they don't really
read but every little bit anything that
can help us remove Donald Trump in
November is something that we should be
looking at very very very seriously and
that's exactly what we're going to do
next I know that a lot of crazy things
have been normalized during the Trump
era but what is in John Bolton's book is
blowing everything else out of the water
I don't know how else to say it now that
we've talked about the bogus attempts to
suppress the release of John Bolton's
book I want to talk about what is
actually in the book and it is I mean
listen I don't want to be hyperbolic but
the sum total of what Bolton alleges in
this book essentially blows every other
Trump scandal out of the water and as
usual if only 5% of what Bolton says in
the book is true it's worse than we ever
imagined that's that's the sort of math
of it now let's get right into the
insanity John Bolton asserts in his book
that in 2019 at the g20 Chinese
President Xi explained to Donald Trump
that he is essentially building
concentration camps to imprison this
Muslim population in China the yogurts
and according to the interpreter present
for that conversation Donald Trump said
to the Chinese president that the camps
should be built and that it is the right
thing to do Donald Trump allegedly
okayed concentration camps for China's
Muslim population in a conversation with
the Chinese president according to John
Bolton this was not an isolated incident
Bolton claims in his book that the top
Asia staffer for the National Security
Council Matthew Pottenger told him that
in 2017 Trump said the exact same thing
about the concentration camp camp for
the youghurt are we guys I'm not exactly
sure the the preferred pronunciation
there this is obviously a completely
unconscionable thing for Donald Trump to
say but what's bonkers is that this is
only the tip of the ice
with John Bolton's book Bolton claims
that on multiple occasions Donald Trump
said he was willing to help end criminal
investigations into major companies in
China and Turkey as favors to presidents
XI and odo on Bolton alleges that Trump
privately told him that reporters
deserve prison and in some cases should
be executed because they are quote
scumbags the allegation is that the
President of the United States said
reporters members of the media should be
either imprisoned or executed for their
reporting john bolton alleges that
donald trump lacked just basic foreign
policy knowledge like as an example
Bolton says Trump didn't know that the
United Kingdom has nuclear weapons
Donald Trump reportedly asked whether
Finland is part of Russia Donald Trump
reportedly said it would be cool to
invade Venezuela Bolton recalled that
White House chief of staff John Kelly
told that story according to the book
during Trump's 2018 meeting with the
North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
Trump's own Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo slipped a note to Bolton saying
Trump is full of s months later
Pompeyo allegedly dismissed trumps
entire North Korea gambit as having a
quote zero probability of success
meanwhile Pompeo publicly was saying
Trump's doing a great job on North Korea
there's an entire additional set of
claims in Bolton's book that has to do
with Donald Trump asking the Chinese
President to help him win in 2020 now
this is particularly stunning because
you might remember we covered this when
it happened a George Stephanopoulos from
ABC actually interviewed Donald Trump
and asked him would you call the FBI if
Russia tried to help you in 2020 if
China tried to help you and Trump said
well I might but I also might look at
the information I might accept them
remember this clip this is somebody that
said we have information on your
opponent oh let me call the FBI give me
a break
life doesn't work the director says
that's what should happen the FBI do
there is wrong your campaign this time
Brad a foreigners if Russia if China if
someone else offers you information on
opponent should they accept it or should
they call the FBI I think maybe you do
both I think you might want to listen I
don't there's nothing wrong with
listening if somebody called from a
country Norway we have information on
your opponent oh I think I'd want to
hear you want that kind of interference
in our elections it's not an
interference they have information I
think I'd take it if I thought there was
something wrong I'd go maybe to the FBI
if I thought there was something wrong
but when somebody comes up with Apple
research right they come up with up or
research oh let's call the FBI the FBI
doesn't have enough agents to take care
of it but you go and talk honestly to
congressmen they all do it they always
have and that's the way it is it's
called Oppo research well it turns out
that this was not merely theoretical for
Donald Trump Trump actually went to the
Chinese president according to Bolton
and asked for help and the way Trump
asked President Xi for help was to
explain listen President Xi farmers are
really important to my re-election in
2020 I need you to help me get reelected
by making larger purchases of soybeans
and wheat from the United States farmers
so this is not just Trump accepting
information this is not just Trump
accepting help this is Trump asking for
help to get reelected lastly for today
on the claims in the book and we
couldn't possibly cover everything
that's in the book Boulton says that
Donald Trump regularly made it clear
that there was an obvious and overt quid
pro quo with Ukraine Boulton says Trump
would regularly say don't send any aid
to Ukraine until we get the materials
about Hillary Clinton and Joe Biden so
again we're going to talk more about
John Bolton being a trader in a little
bit you don't have to believe John
Bolton is a good person because he's not
you don't have to excuse John Bolton's
sick role as an architect of the Iraq
war to realize that if even 5% of what
he says in the book is true this is the
most insane story or set of allegations
about Donald Trump from the beginning
John Bolton has done many bad things but
Bolton I don't believe is just going to
make up all of this stuff out
thin air when you realize that nothing
that Bolton claims is out of character
with Trump that also is part of the
picture here now why didn't John Bolton
say it seven months ago
why didn't John Bolton show up and say
it in front of the House impeachment
committee Bolton should have told us
sooner and he's even sicker because of
the fact that he didn't we are going to
get to that later on in the program he
is not going to be excused for for that
but the claims are absolutely and
completely stunning and the fact that
Bolton waited to do it in a book is
pathetic and it's just part of Bolton's
worldview which big picture I completely
disagree with let me know your reaction
to the assertions on Twitter I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and later we will
talk about how we should judge Bolton or
how he decided to do all of this the
david pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read ten books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinka Stan what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinka snakes sure that you're getting
all of the important core insights from
each book so it's perfect for exploring
a book you otherwise wouldn't have time
for there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blankets to get
a sample first just think how much you
can enrich yourself by being able to
soak up an entire nonfiction book in
just 15 minutes I recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
Stephen Hawking this is a book that I
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blink Asst
blink East has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
east comm slash David Pakman I've put
the link right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com big thank you to today's new
members of the day Andrew Lindsay and
Deanna Bell also an extra thank you to
today's longtime sustaining member
that's Thomas Radford Thomas has been a
member for almost five years join and
support alternatives to homogeneous
corporate media grab a membership at
join pakman.com ok I was browsing the
David Pakman show subreddit this morning
which of course you can find at david
pakman.com slash reddit we have
surpassed twenty thousand subscribers to
the david pakman show reddit one of the
largest independent progressive media
subreddits on reddit if you can believe
that a user posted an article called
trump has a point about the polls from
Politico and the gist of this article is
that there were some state polls in 2016
that were wrong and there were some
state polls in 2016 that said Hillary
Clinton was going to win by a small
margin and Trump won by a small margin
and certainly that's true and you know
my goal on this show has been not to
inaccurately a sale polling more than it
deserves but also not to hold polling up
as any kind of immutable and and
unchanging metric that tells us exactly
what's going to happen in November in
2016 the polls were widely accurate the
national polls said Hillary Clinton was
going to win by three and she won by a
little more than two that that means
they were right they were the results
were within the margin of error in most
states they were right it is true that
when states are really really close
sometimes state polling that is done
even five days before the election may
not reflect who is going to win that
state and certainly Michigan Wisconsin
and some other states are examples of
that so what we should take away from
this is not that polling is widely
untrustworthy when we are talking about
highly rated pollsters it's
understanding that there's a margin of
error and that things can change also in
the last
few days before an election so if it
tells us anything it's that no matter
what state you're voting in you need to
vote and that no matter what the polls
say you need to vote that's the message
and there's no you know there's no big
revelation about the the particularly
inaccurate polling in 2016 the polls
were mostly right nationally and at the
state level the polls did not account
for some momentum and swings in Trump's
direction close to the end of the
campaign and there were states where
Hillary was leading in the polls and she
ultimately lost what that tells us as
the polls give us a sense of what's
going on but we need to absolutely crush
turnout to ensure that Trump doesn't end
up winning some of these states by
eleven thousand votes again like he did
in Michigan that's the takeaway another
post on the subreddit is about YouTube
autoplay up pointing out that no matter
how many of my clips people watch on
YouTube they still get last week tonight
recommended instead of more David Pakman
show clips this is an ongoing issue with
YouTube's algorithm we actually have a
new a really great study from mark LED
which who has been studying this stuff
about exactly how the YouTube algorithm
has hurt our channel it's an excellent
piece that mark did which I'll present
to you when we have some time it's not
the most urgent thing but maybe next
week I'll have a little time to talk to
you about it so yeah YouTube if you
watch corporate media will recommend you
corporate media if you watch alternative
independent media like the David Pakman
show YouTube will still mostly recommend
you corporate media so the best thing to
do is you subscribe to our channel on
YouTube you hit the bell to tell YouTube
you actually want to be notified you
want to see all of our posts in your
feed and maybe even via email if you
want but don't feel obligated to do that
that's really the best way to ensure
that you are not missing our content
lastly a user named bacon and caffeine
is criticizing my pronunciation of the
state whose abbreviation is FL saying
David it's Florida not Lara da so I'm
from Massachusetts
and here unless you're from certain
neighborhoods in Boston you print you do
pronounce at Florida when I say Florida
I'm sort of joking that's the the New
York accent way of pronouncing Florida
you know I I I am Jewish and I do have
relatives who have moved from from New
York to Florida and their pronunciation
is Florida I understand
but both are certainly valid
pronunciations thank you okay join the
discussion at david pakman.com slash
reddit all right before we go back to
talking about john bolton
i want to talk with you today about
corporations supporting black lives
matter and donating to black lives
matter and i want to hear from you about
whether you believe that i am too
cynical about this issue because i dont
believe corporations supporting or not
supporting black lives matter is really
indicative of any of their moral points
of view or even necessarily of the
politics of the company these mostly our
business calculations and i'm actually
going to go even further in the analysis
this is by design we should not even
expect corporations to really function
on any basis other than how much money
is this going to make us because this is
how they are designed in particular
publicly traded corporations have a
fiduciary responsibility to their
shareholders to deliver a return and to
make money so my personal view is
corporations should be responsible to
all stakeholders now when we say
stakeholders that's bigger than
shareholders stakeholders include
society it includes the economy more
broadly it includes the environment this
is not the way corporations operates so
all sorts of different companies we've
seen you know Target Home Depot Etsy H&M
on the list of companies supporting
black lives matter
some donating to black lives matter and
affiliated causes I don't really think
it matters in terms of figuring out the
morality of these companies tons of
companies have said you know we're
committed to fighting injustice
some say they're committed to dealing
with systemic racism others are donating
money or whatever now to the extent that
they're handing cash over the money can
be used to fight these battles and
that's good and the money is money no
matter who donated it but fundamentally
at the corporate level these are
business calculations I was thinking
back to my first appearance on the Joe
Rogan program we were having a
conversation about Google and Joe felt
that Google is a left-wing company
because they have a non-discrimination
policy for trans workers that includes
you you refer to people by their
preferred gender pronouns and so Joe
felt that Google was a left-wing company
on that basis my position was that a
non-discrimination policy from a human
resources standpoint doesn't really tell
us whether the company's right-wing or
left-wing in terms of its place in the
world and in fact I said to Joe Google
is part of the anti regulation avoid
taxes movement that's often more
associated with the right than the left
in the United States but the truth is
that all of this stuff
has one focus how can Google gain market
share and how can Google make more money
having the LGBT non-discrimination
policy probably helps their bottom line
more than it hurts it from a PR
perspective just like lobbying against
taxes helps their bottom line lobbying
against regulation helps their bottom
line and much the same way that's the
lens through which I see this corporate
support of black lives matter now it's
important to mention I'm not denying for
a second that many of the individuals
who work at these companies probably do
support black lives matter from a
personal standpoint I am sure that many
of them oppose police brutality I am
sure that many of the workers and even
executives at these companies agree with
the protests because most of the country
agrees with the reasons for the protests
but much like I often say we shouldn't
deify individual politicians they're
just people they're right on some things
that wrong on some other things we
should not attribute certain agency to
corporations when all we can really say
is
they've calculated their options and
have made a business decision the
business decisions might sometimes
coincide with the political feelings of
the executives you might have a
situation where the executives support
black lives matter and supporting black
lives matter is good for the company's
bottom line it's all beautiful it's all
hunky dory kumbaya and it's it's that's
the way that it all goes down but at no
point should we lose sight of the
reality that if it were really bad for a
corporation to support black lives
matter based on their customer base and
other factors they would be dramatically
less likely to say we support the
protests or black lives matter or are
donating so tell me what you think am I
being overly cynical here am i
oversimplifying some component of this I
want to hear from you I believe that
corporate support of black lives matter
not I'm not talking about the
individuals at the company's corporate
support of black lives matter is merely
a calculated business decision I want to
hear from you we will have more about
this on our Instagram page which is
david pakman show all one word on
instagram follow us there we'll take a
quick break
much more about the John Bolton Donald
Trump scandal coming up after this short
break the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show okay so earlier
on the on in the show I told you about
the claims that john bolton makes in his
book donald trump okaying
Chinese concentration camps Trump saying
invading Venezuela would be cool Trump
asking China for help getting reelected
a trump saying reporters should be
imprisoned or executed Trump didn't know
that the UK had nuclear weapons on and
on and on we did that earlier in the
show I then told you about the legal
battle by Trump's Justice Department to
suppress the publication of John
Bolton's book including a footnote
provision that is asking courts to ban
bookstores from selling Bolton's book
under threat of punishment or legal
action so we already did all of that
stuff now I want to talk about Donald
Trump's reaction Donald Trump
predictably was so triggered by what is
in John Bolton's book that he absolutely
exploded both on television and on
Twitter it's been going for almost 24
hours now we just had to add more tweets
to this story because Trump just won't
stop tweeting so here is Trump kicking
it off last night with Sean Hannity Fox
News propagandists total total
disinformation whitewashing attempt of
of the entire story calling Bolton a
washed-up criminal let's take a look at
this clip and then in terms of Bolton he
broke the law he was a washed up guy I
gave him a chance
he couldn't get Senate confirmed so I
gave him an on Senate
confirmed position where I could just
put him there see how he worked and I
wasn't very enamored he went into the
Middle East he was one of the the big
guns for let's go into Iraq and that
didn't work out too well and I was
against that a long time ago before I
was ever even thinking about doing what
I'm doing now but he was one of the
people wanted to go to Iraq when I asked
him about it I said recently I said you
know about a month in when he was about
a month in I said what do you think you
think you made a mistake there no I
don't think so I don't think so I said
explain that one
so the terrible terrible thing that he
did but he broke the law very simple I
mean as much as it's going to be broken
this is highly classified that's the
highest stage it's highly classified
information that he did not have
approval so on this is this is amazing
Trump says both that bolton's claims are
lies and that they're classified if
they're lies how are they classified
it's made up stuff right it just doesn't
make any sense
and Trump's also funny because he says
Bolton was bad because he went into Iraq
and Trump hired him fifteen years later
knowing that doesn't Trump say he hires
the best people so Trump making no sense
if it's lies how are they classified
if you hire the best people why did you
hire someone that is so terrible and
then the real triggering Trump clearly
sitting there fermenting with his phone
tweet after embarrassing tweet and I
want to look at a couple of these with
you Donald Trump retweeting right-wing
disinformation propagator Dinesh D'Souza
who attacked Boulton Donald Trump adding
to D'Souza's tweet President Bush fired
him also Bolton is incompetent Trump
calling Bolton a wacko and a dope
tweeting quote wacko but John Bolton's
exceedingly tedious book is made up of
Lies and fake stories said all good
about me in print until the day I fired
him a disgruntled boring fool who only
wanted to go to war never had a clue was
ostracized and happily dumped what a
dope and I go back again if they're lies
how is it a problem
that Bolton is publishing classified
information if he's making it all up it
by definition couldn't be classified
because it doesn't really exist right
Trump kept going this morning completely
out of control
saying quote Bolton's book which is
getting terrible reviews is a
compilation of Lies and made-up stories
all intended to make me look bad
many of the ridiculous statements he
attributes to me were never made pure
fiction just trying to get even for
firing him like the sick puppy he is and
again if it's all lies why are you
suppressing it on the basis of it being
classified and then a - series to tweet
series where he says quote when Wakko
John Bolton went on to face the nation
and so stupidly said that he looked at
the Libyan model for North Korea all
hell broke out Kim jong-un who we were
getting along with very well went
ballistic just like his missiles and
rightfully so he didn't want Bolton
anywhere near him Bolton's dumbest of
all statements set us back very badly
with North Korea even now I asked him
what the hell were you thinking he had
no answer and just apologized that was
early on I should have fired him right
then and there now we could do an hour
on Trump with North Korea and his
delusions the real problem with North
Korea was Trump falling for the same
stuff that North Korean leaders have
been doing and saying for 30 years
Trump's actually believed it right other
presidents both Democrat and Republican
knew that they shouldn't fall for the
idiotic and unbelievable claims from
North Korean leaders Trump fell for them
so Trump thought he was making progress
so I mean I don't even know where where
to start all of this right Fox's
position has been to get experts on
saying Bolton's book in dangers our
national security by putting out
classified and secret information well
Trump says it's all lies so how can lies
be secret and classified at the same
time the real risk to our national
security all along has been Donald Trump
remember Trump once tweeted what
should have been a classified and
remained classified satellite photo
national security means nothing to Trump
Trump once had a meeting with Russians
in the Oval Office and shared Israeli
intelligence with them which he had not
been given the okay to share which
endangered an actual important source of
information about Isis for example which
Donald Trump claimed to be fighting very
very strongly about so if you want to
talk about endangering national security
and playing fast and loose with what
should be secret and classified
information and I say should because I
understand legally Trump can declassify
whatever he wants doesn't mean it's
smart or prudent to do it really it's
Trump we need to be looking at and again
I I have a tweet about this which you
can look at i'm deepak mint on twitter
how is it that trump is furious that
bolton is both lying but that what he
writes in the book is classified
information if they are lies it doesn't
exist it's made up and therefore being
classified wouldn't actually be a
problem i'm sure that the trumpets will
find some way to excuse that completely
incoherent claim but it is not making
too much sense now let's dig in I've
been building to this Bolton deserves
huge criticism for what he did to some
degree and that's where we're going to
go next
so it has to be said john bolton is a
traitor to the interests of the United
States I believe John Bolton's
absolutely stunning claims in his book
about Donald Trump I believe John Bolton
is telling the truth as he sees it and
that the stories he tells in the book
are mostly accurate I believe Trump
okayed Weger concentration camps in
China I believe Trump said invading
Venezuela is cool I believed from past
China for help getting reelected I
believe Trump said reporters should be
imprisoned or executed I believe Trump
didn't know that the UK had nuclear
weapons why do I believe it because it
passes the sniff test and it correlates
it seems to be corroborated by three and
a half years of similar claims about
Donald Trump I
people who have been around him but john
bolton is a traitor
why is john bolton a traitor because he
waited seven months to make these claims
in public now you're going to see
criticisms of Bolton and of people on
the Left who essentially believe Bolton
is you know in broad strokes telling the
truth here you're starting to see some
people on the Left say you idiot
leftists you fell for the fake Russia
story you faked fell for the fake
Ukraine story you fell for impeachment
which was which was never going to
remove Donald Trump which we said by the
way and now you're falling for the same
type of nonsense from a horrible guy who
is a terrible neocon and led us into war
with Iraq and bla bla bla bla bla no no
no no no that's not the case john bolton
does not get a pass here but just
because someone's a terrible person
doesn't mean everything they're saying
is untrue these allegations that john
bolton is making are so serious that it
is an inexcusable miscarriage of
morality for him to have waited seven
months before going public now I get it
Bolton has a book to sell you monetize
what you know and it made sense
financially for him to wait number two
the book was being vetted so conceivably
if Bolton just goes public with all of
this stuff in December when the
manuscript was turned over to the
National Security Council and it hasn't
yet been vetted
maybe there's a legal issue or whatever
the case may be but john bolton wants us
to believe that he's doing this because
it's for the good of the country
to know what donald trump has been up to
behind the scenes well i agree but if
his concerns are the good of the country
we should have known about it seven
months ago or eight or nine months ago
or you know a lot of this stuff happened
even earlier and and john bolton could
have talked about it at the time I
cannot forgive john bolton for that if
5% of what bolton claims in the book is
true there would have been multiple
cases for impeaching donald trump now
with the republican-controlled senate
trump still wouldn't have been convicted
and removed on impeachment but john
bolton
has criticized Democrats for not going
after Trump more strongly on more issues
on impeachment well he could have told
us what some of those issues were he
refused to testify before the house
impeachment committee unless he was
subpoenaed which is not uncommon but
again if bolton is the patriot who's
telling us this because the country
deserves to know he could have figured
out a way to tell us the seven eight
nine months ago
aside from testifying at any point in
time John Bolton could have said you
know what this is so serious this is so
important that I am going to take a
personal legal risk and I'm gonna do
interviews and I'm gonna talk about what
I saw he still could have written a book
people still would have bought the book
seven months later but he could have
given a seven months of a head start and
many things could have gone differently
in the last seven months Bolton writes
in his book that when he saw Trump asked
China for help getting reelected he
believed it was a threat to American
interests and he said nothing he was
national security adviser his concern is
national security and he said nothing
about something that he believed to be a
threat to US interests Bolton the
patriot sees a threat is in charge of
national security and waits to publish a
book in order to go public that is not
patriotic
that is not patriotic so Bolton going
public on all this stuff as Eli Hoenig
wrote in an op-ed for CNN Bolton could
have changed the course of history had
he gone public 7 months ago with this
stuff so do I believe Bolton is making
this stuff up I don't I believe Bolton
is telling the truth as he sees it and
that the book is mostly accurate maybe
there are some details that are not
because all of the claims line up with
what we've known about Donald Trump for
three and a half years none of these
claims seem outlandish in the context of
what we know about Donald Trump but in
the same way that Donna John Bolton
betrayed the country in 2003 by pushing
the Iraq war Bolton betrayed the United
States by waiting 7 months to make these
claims public these are things that he
knew would have been worthy of
impeachment and he waited for the
opportunity to
make money by selling books now let's
get back to what I know many of you are
going to say why does it matter about
impeachment impeachable claims if a
Republican Senate would not have removed
Trump either way that is true but it
would have been much worse for the
Senate to acquit Trump in light of five
impeachable offenses most of them even
crazier than the Ukraine story then to
impeach attend to acquit Trump only on
the Ukraine story Trump directly asked
China for support getting reelected he
told China concentration camps are the
right thing to do
Trump obstructed investigations into
Turkish individuals and businesses as a
favor to her on seeing Republicans
acquit Trump in light of five solid
impeachment cases might have been a
difference maker in some of the upcoming
reelection campaigns of senators in
November that's one example that what
would be a material difference there is
no way that Bolton going public earlier
helps Trump and it might have hurt Trump
and it might have hurt Republicans
hugely so Bolton was and still is an
outrageous war Hawk who wants to see
American military personnel in more
places around the world for corporate
profits or neoconservative political
goals John Bolton probably is at least
partially motivated by a bruised ego
related to how everything went down with
Donald Trump but John Bolton is not
going to just make up everything that he
said in the book and yet he is still a
traitor the right thing to do if it's
out of love of country would have been
for him to make these claims publicly
seven months ago he cannot be forgiven
for that but that doesn't mean what he's
saying in the book is untrue and a lot
of these lame just lame lame lame hot
takes from some supposedly lists
completely ignore that Bolton can be a
bad guy and the claims can still be true
Trump can have done the things Bolton
alleges and yet it could still have been
wrong for Bolton to make the case to go
into Iraq which it was wrong and I
hope that we don't see much of the left
go down that this very very wrong headed
rabbit hole let's take a quick break we
will talk about the economy coming up we
will talk about coronavirus a lot more
news in the last 24 hours than merely
John Bolton the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
okay it's Thursday which means we do
have jobs numbers in the last week 1.5
million more people have lost their jobs
remember that this is once again a
number that before the coronavirus era
would have been twice the single week
new unemployment claim record which was
about 700,000 prior to coronavirus in
one week we have blown that out of the
water for 13 straight weeks now record
job losses peaking of course with 6.8
million people losing their jobs in one
week in late March then we saw declining
to 5 million 4 million a week 3 million
2 million the last couple of weeks about
one and a half million people each week
lost their jobs so this brings the total
number of jobs lost during coronavirus
to just over 45 million now to put that
number in context before the virus
pandemic started the workforce was
believed to be a hundred and fifty eight
million people 45 million jobs have been
lost during this pandemic in 13 weeks
and that is about 28 percent of the
total US workforce now it's very
important to know and I have no interest
in hiding from you obviously that some
of the people who lost their jobs have
already found new jobs so if you want to
find good news or maybe not terrible
news the job losses are decelerating
meaning each week we have fewer people
losing their jobs that's good would be
better but to completely turn it around
we also maybe most importantly are
seeing that the last two weeks more
people found jobs in other words they
went back to work compared to the number
of people who lost their jobs so like
even though in the last week 1.5 million
more people lost jobs slightly more than
that went back to work so the total
number of active unemployed people
actually went down it's a very small
change we went from 20 point six million
unemployed to 20 point five million
unemployed ok so that's important now to
say it a different way 45 million people
total have lost jobs during the pandemic
but 20 million are currently unemployed
meaning a large number of people have
gone back to work now what's the obvious
problem the problem is we're in the
middle of a pandemic I know that Donald
Trump is pretending as though the
pandemic is over a lot of red states are
pretending as though the pandemic is
over we're going to hear in the
voicemail segment today from someone
living in Hawaii but we are still in the
middle of a pandemic the job losses are
slowing down which is good but the
pandemic is raging and it's actually
worse than it has ever been in many
states so here in the United States
overall we are still finding about
20,000 cases a day the last few days
it's been more like twenty-two
twenty-three twenty-four thousand cases
the seven-day average of new cases is
going up actually and it has been going
up for ten days but then you look at
specific states you look at Texas you
look at Florida you look at Arizona and
other states they're spiking
dramatically and they appear to be
nowhere near their peaks so look at the
context right if these job jobs numbers
that we are seeing now are starting to
be less bad because some states are
totally wide open but coronavirus is
still raging we have one of two possible
futures jobs continue to get less bad as
way more people die from coronavirus
right we are to open the jobs improve
but deaths absolutely get disastrously
worse or we are going to have to shut
down again at least some states are
going to have to shut down again and we
are going to see the jobs numbers get
worse again now we've seen some states
like Texas Texas is seeing this is the
worst week since the beginning for Texas
Texas has made it pretty clear under
their Republican governor ship that they
don't have an appetite to close down
again they seem to be taking the
approach of it's gonna be what its gonna
be protect yourselves if you don't want
to go out don't go out but we're opening
and we're going to be staying opening
what is becoming very clear is until you
have a really effective treatment and/or
vaccine you
can't have both a serious jobs recovery
and limit spread because some stuff
needs to remain closed some stuff needs
to remain closed I'm hopeful that here
in Massachusetts because we've gone
slowly we have a very moderate
Republican governor here he could have
acted a little more quickly early on
Charlie Baker but he widely has done a
good job we've gone the the planning has
been phased and the phasing has been
planned as I like to say and we have
gone step by step and it's a slower
recovery but the point is that hopefully
it's a more permanent recovery that will
get us to have some degree of economic
recovery up to the point at which we
have a vaccine and or effective
treatment effective treatment excuse me
and in some states they are not taking
precautions and they're pretending
everything's fine and so while their
jobs recovery may have been faster in
the immediate their coronavirus cases
and eventually deaths are going to get
really really bad and we would expect to
see that probably by the end of next
week you would see a lot of the cases
from early this week start tragically
translating to death so we're going to
follow it okay let's now talk about a
little bit about dr. Anthony Fauci
months ago the Trump administration made
it clear as I just told you a few
minutes ago they're moving past
coronavirus they're done with
coronavirus at least from the standpoint
of talking publicly about the virus and
the pandemic we saw the press briefings
essentially eliminated when Donald Trump
wondered aloud about injecting bleach
and isopropyl alcohol putting them into
the body as he says to treat coronavirus
the press briefings stopped a couple of
weeks ago we heard from dr. Anthony
Fauci that he was speaking to Donald
Trump less and less frequently and this
week in an interview two days ago doctor
foul she confirmed he has not spoken to
Donald Trump at all in more than two
weeks
remember dr. Anthony Fauci is the
director of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Disease he's
essentially the top infectious disease
doctor in the country he has made it
very clear over the last week that
dates that aren't ready to reopen really
shouldn't reopen he has made it clear
that if states open and businesses don't
stick to the guidelines that are
established it's going to go really
badly doctor foul she said a few days
ago very specifically he would not go to
donald trump's tulsa oklahoma rally this
saturday that's a bad idea
he wouldn't go to any other events like
it either and now he has confirmed that
the last time he spoke to donald trump
is more than two weeks ago and even then
trump only wanted to know about what was
going on with vaccines and this is
because we know trump is increasingly
obsessed with vaccines not for health
reasons but because he believes that a
vaccine is something he could take
credit for to justify his reelection in
November the last time Trump and foul
Chi spoke they didn't talk about
coronavirus exploding in many states
they didn't talk about cases
hospitalizations resurgence spread it
was just what's going on with the
vaccine because Donald Trump thinks
that's something he could use to get
himself reelected so this is not an
accident my friends from the standpoint
of the political position of the Trump
administration the corona virus pandemic
is over and we are now what's that it's
the the return to greatness or what RiRi
oh I forget what the stupid propaganda
term Trump came up with is something
about greatness
that's what Trump sees right now and
Trump even said this week you don't do
any more testing you won't find any more
cases problem solved right haven't you
taken a look at the stock market
everything's great now just stop testing
and then we won't have any cases how
many Americans are going to die because
Donald Trump never took this seriously
and then stopped taking it seriously
after only taking it seriously for a
very short period of time how many
Americans are going to die because
Donald Trump by even having a huge rally
is implicitly signaling to his
supporters you can gather in large
groups
go ahead listen I'm having 10,000 people
at my rally you can go ahead and have 20
people over no big deal and of course
then the spread will continue the
president has not even spoken to the top
infectious disease
doctor in two weeks and more Americans
have now died of coronavirus than the
number that died in World War one
there's all sorts of different metrics
and statistics that have been put
together comparing the death toll to all
sorts of other horrible horrible things
so Trump is trying to make coronavirus
go away by ignoring it it's you know we
could have that object permanence
conversation again about little kids
unfortunately and this is the the real
tragedy he's convinced tens of millions
of Americans to do the exact same thing
we I've been speaking to friends in
Florida friends in Arizona
people are just mostly acting like
everything's fine yeah you still have
some people wearing masks and staying
home but the virus doesn't need that
many people to gather to continue
spreading more and more quickly six US
states are seeing record highs in cases
twenty US states are seeing increases
the six big culprits are Florida Texas
Arizona Oklahoma Oregon and Nevada in
terms of percentage growth and they have
had their highest single day spikes in
the last week
now in some cities within these states
things are so bad that bars have started
to close even though they're allowed to
be open so there's a place in
Jacksonville Florida Lynch's pub so many
of their employees and customers got
coronavirus that even though they're
allowed to be open according to the
Florida guidelines that are currently in
place they said we have to close because
this is absolutely crazy so we are now
in the please disperse move along
nothing to see here phase of the
pandemic except much like in the Leslie
Nielsen movie Naked Gun explosions are
going on in the background while they
say move along nothing to see here
step back nothing has been resolved the
broken healthcare system hasn't been
fixed the underlying economic fragility
of our system has not been addressed we
are not any better prepared for the next
outbreak we still aren't testing enough
we have no plan to prevent a second wave
if we even get a break between waves one
and two literally nothing has been fixed
although fortunately some states and
we're going to
one state in a moment some states are
doing enough to modestly keep things
under control okay we have a voicemail
number and that number is two one nine
two david p you can call absolutely any
time that you would like here's a caller
from hawaii who gets some of the numbers
wrong but still makes a good point let's
take a listen hey david this is ron out
in hawaii I'm on the Big Island of
Hawaii right June 17 20 20 we haven't
had a case of coronavirus in days maybe
weeks so that's not true in fact if you
look at the numbers you see that Hawaii
has had new cases every single day but
very very few very very few and yet when
I go out and I drive around and I go to
public places people are wearing masks
we have no cases right island and people
are following protocol people are making
sure to keep 6-foot distance so when I
see reports of Texas and Arizona and
people pretending that there's no virus
right I really can't understand why and
it makes me so happy that I decided to
move to an island in the middle of the
Pacific Ocean during understo think we
got cut out there I I totally get the
feeling listen I I'm not in an isle on
an island in Massachusetts but I I'm
also very glad that I'm here and not in
you know Texas or as Arizona or Florida
or wherever else so Hawaii does have
some cases I was just looking at the
numbers before coming on on air but they
have very few they've managed it very
very well and people listen that the
guidelines work that's the reality the
guidelines work and you can say what you
want about death rates or mortality or
age or any of this other stuff the
guidelines work and you've got to stick
to them and just having the guidelines
isn't enough you actually need buy-in
from people to do the things that you
are asking them to do and my fear is I
take no pleasure in this because then
any death is a death it's all horrible
my fear is that what we're going to see
in some of these states that have
decided we're just not shutting down
it's just not happening no matter what
happens
we may be seeing things that are even
worse than anything we've seen so far in
some of these states upcoming
increasingly increasing warnings about
ICU and hospital capacity being stressed
to the absolute max
in some states it's bad and the the
question will be will it start to bleed
over into the states that are doing the
right things because of interstate
travel we don't know we're going to
watch all of this stuff very very
closely okay we have a tremendous bonus
show for you today get the bonus show by
becoming a member at join pakman.com or
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
remember that the daily audio podcast is
always available if you watch on YouTube
or Facebook clips and you would rather
just get the full hour audio podcast
it's available for free on iTunes
stitcher google play podcasts Spotify
Pandora it's almost too available
it's too easy to get the audio podcast
subscribe to it for free and get the
daily show every single day
thanks so much for watching today's a
full episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinka the app that
lets you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try blink is for free and save 25%
off of a subscription when you go to
blink is comm slash David Pakman I've
also included the link right underneath
this video